foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody so rapper ynw
Melly is seven weeks out from his
retrial in South Florida and his defense
team believes that that time should be
spent out on bond a motion appeared
Wednesday in the Broward County court
docket asking for an Arthur hearing for
the first time since smelly's been in
custody the south Florida rapper whose
real name is Jamel demons is accused of
killing two of his close friends Anthony
Williams and Christopher Thomas back in
2018. prosecutors believe that Mellie
along with his co-defendant Courtland
Henry shot the two men while the group
was in a Jeep and then staged the
alleged gang-related murders to look
like a drive-by shooting melly's defense
team argues that their client had no
reason to kill his close friends and
there's insufficient evidence to prove
it Melly faced the death penalty in his
first double murder trial held in June
and July but the 12 panel jury couldn't
reach a unanimous verdict and it ended
in a mistrial prosecutors are set to
retry melee again in October in the
meantime his defense team argues that
Melody's been in jail for over four
years and he's title to bond for several
reasons one of those being that
prosecutors could improve their case
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt the first time
around and his co-defendant Courtland
Henry has been out on bond despite
facing the same charges the only
difference of course is that melee faces
the death penalty while Henry does not
the bond hearing is set for Friday so
Brian why do a bond hearing now after
the trial I feel like there's an
advantage there right yeah so you can
actually ask for a change of bond at any
time in someone's criminal case but you
typically have to wait for what's called
a change of circumstances and this I
think does create a change of
circumstances where they say hey judge
regardless of whether it was 1 to 11 or
11 to 1 to a quit they could not get all
12. and at least in his mind the charges
are a little bit weaker and he has more
aspirations of fighting this case let
him be out while he fights it however on
the flip side the prosecution they were
quick to say let's do this trial right
away that somewhat negates that because
they say hey our trial is about to start
right now he's not going to be
languishing in jail for or for months
and months on end to the next trial so
it's a bit of a balancing act there so
Brian's right in mellie's mind and maybe
in a lot of legal analysts mind the case
looks a lot weaker than it did when it
started having said that does it look
weaker in the mind of the core because
he still tried he's still facing the
charges of double murder where they
where the Judgment say okay now you can
you be out because that didn't change
he's still charged with the double
murder here well not only is he still
charged with a double murder he's also
has the death penalty that's basically
that's true I think the judge is going
to look at this as a very serious case
and I think judge Murphy is going to
think very carefully about what is
happening with Cortland Henry remember
he is also trying that case so that case
is going to have to be I think postponed
because you can't do both at the same
time unless they assign it to another
judge but I think as far as bond is
concerned Mellie has been I think so far
based on everything we've seen a very
good person as far as being behind bars
he hasn't caused any trouble he's
appeared in court he hasn't been
outraged just in any way shape or form
and I think they can set it up so that
he has restrictions the way Henry has
restrictions so the judge could Grant
the bond it doesn't seem like they're
going to be dropping the death penalty
aspect of it have you ever seen a case
before where somebody the death penalty
is on the table and they're actually out
on bond pending the trial I don't I
can't remember I cannot thank you
because at the end of the day there's a
number of reasons why people are
considered to be a Flight Risk and the
biggest one usually is the type of
punishment they're facing this is the
highest level of punishment in this
country so it would be a reason for
someone to flee okay big decision for
the judge when we come back more
coverage in South Florida as rapper ynw
Melly awaits his retrial the new
addition to melly's defense team and new
possible strategies for jury selection
what's next
foreign
[Music]
back everybody so we're finishing
Today's Show with more coverage of the
ynw Melly Saga out in South Florida the
rapper's retrial is set for October in a
death penalty case for double murder but
two questions still remain one will
Mellie wait behind bars or out on Bond
and two what will be different in court
a second time around well Mellie whose
real name is Jamel demons is accused of
killing two of his close friends in
2018. prosecutors believe that Melly and
co-defendant Courtland Henry shot the
two victims while they were in a Jeep
and then staged the alleged gang-related
murders to look like a drive-by melly's
defense team believes that the state
lacks both motive and forensic evidence
to tie their client to the case melee
faced the death penalty in his double
murder trial which started in June and
by July ended in a mistrial while
Melody's retrial is still more than six
weeks out and Arthur hearing is
scheduled for Friday to see if Melly is
eligible for Bond now also noted on the
court docket was a change in attorneys
melly's stacked defense team has
switched out attorney David Howard for
Jamie Benjamin former president of
several lawyer associations and winner
of several death penalty cases jury
selection and melly's retrial is
scheduled to begin October 9th Terry new
legal Team new strategy what do you
think well I think the new legal team
should make sure that they touch base
with the old legal team and some of the
old legal team is still there one of the
things I think they will do differently
here because I had a conversation when I
was down there with the attorneys I
think they're going to try or they
should to put in an expert to battle
what was said on the prosecution side as
far as that expert was concerned for the
trajectory of those bullets because
that's one of the things I think the
jury looked at very seriously how those
bullets were shot and how they could
only come from where we know that Mellie
was sitting in their car at least when
he got in so I expect to see at least
one expert to put some more reasonable
doubt in the minds of more of those
juries whether it was nine to three or
three to nine or whether it's just one
person
I think they need to have more expert
opinion in there and if they can put
another fact witness in someone else who
was sitting in that second vehicle but
you know we'll see what happens the
question is they got one Adrian Davis
can they get someone else who is sitting
in that second Jeep to come well the
reporting is the rumor mill is is that
there was one hold out that convinced
two other jurors to vote not guilty for
uh y w Melly now that he's getting this
new defense team you hear Mr Benjamin's
experience in death penalty cases what
do you think what do you think the
strategy is going to be focus on the
jury it's not necessarily I think the
facts are the facts I don't think
there's going to be a wild or drastic
change as to what we heard from this
second trial and so when I think of that
it's less about what you can tell it's
more about who you can tell it to and so
if I'm the defense I'm looking for
strong personalities because clearly one
person was able to convince two others
if you believe the rumors and I'm
looking for strong personalities who
will believe what I'm saying to them
either in my definition of what I'm
talking about the prosecution's burden
that they cannot prove the case Beyond a
reasonable doubt that there's too much
circumstantial evidence or just in
connecting my client that being ynw
Melly to someone who's personal in their
life I'm looking for the right person
who's going to buy what I'm selling and
I was just going to ask you I mean I'll
you can jump on the Terry but I was just
going to ask you if you're surprised
that David Howard was removed from the
team I thought he did a phenomenal job
well not only you a lot of people
thought he did a phenomenal job and I
was very surprised but it's up to ynw
Melly as to whether or not he wants to
have him on the team I was just going to
say as far as what Brian was concerned
the jury is very important remember this
is a death penalty jury and that makes
it harder for the defense because you
have to make sure you have people who
will give the death penalty well or open
open to it open to it thanks Terry
thanks Brian everyone out there thanks
for joining us here on Long crime daily
we're going to see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America
thank you
[Music]
foreign